in music you're basically having a
conversation
it's a question here's an answer
oh it's a bit of a dodgy question here
i am convinced that i have no idea how
to do your movie it's always
a blank piece of paper
[Music]
i can tell you everything you need to
know in one word
story
all we're doing set designer actor
writer
composer we try to create worlds
sherlock it's the score
anybody could do one microphone on a
laptop
ideas are not limited by budget the
creative process takes place in your
head
the interesting ideas come from some kid
in a
garage in the bronx you just need to
break through the mess
that you can't create a great hollywood
blockbuster on an ipad
because if you're on story you can do
whatever you want to do
[Music]
i like writing in d and it's nice that
if you go
from
[Music]
it's satisfying for batman
four french horns on the right four
finish homes on the left
and they're up in a gallery up way above
the orchestra
two notes but the amount of
expressiveness you can put into them
[Music]
this is a musician's life everybody
tells you not to do it and get a real
job
when all is said and done and we built
the highest high rises and we built the
fastest machines
there's still going to be room for
somebody to tell you a story
or somebody to write your piece of music
the seconds of your life are taken away
if somebody tells you that there's a
rule break it
that's the only thing that moves things
forward
i'm han zimmer and this is my master
class
you